wenn auch 21 uhr morgens du bist aus
mallorca direkt dahin gekommen was
machst du auf mallorca auf mallorca
ich bin partyschlager anhänger neben
meiner schauspieler tätigkeiten der
lindenstraße und sonst wo bin ich 22 uhr
in der mega arena
ich war noch nicht da muss ich ehrlich
zu sein ist super wirklich also die
bilder aus dem fernsehen nur saufgelage
ist und so die kosten darum oder so
längst nicht das ist wirklich so die
leute fliegen dahin wollen feiern und
das tun sie mit ihren abgeschaltet
einmal zweimal das nach 2 uhr in der
mega arena unten und kenner bis zu 4000
leute rein und dann freitags bis zu 6000
leute ja aber ich hole sie 24 stunden
also fast zehn leute gefühl wenn man
tausende menschen
ich sag mal ja wirklich in wallung
bringt oder das ist geil
für mich muss man noch nie im leben und
ich liebe und lebe das und ich glaube
das merken die leute also ich gehe wenn
ich auf der bühne stehe
wieso schalte dann macht klick und dann
bin ich bin wie ich vorher genau so
verstellen besteht ja ich bin die
spinnen ok und du hast neuen titel
dieses jahr wird weil jedes jahr einen
neuen titel haben wie man wegen wie
läuft das geschäft nur heinz schon okay
aber wenn man sich macht so 2 titel aber
winter so après ski zeit und einem
sommer und diesmal
wahrscheinlich in den gold kiste
gegraben ja weil die nummer gerade der
absolute ober mörler gedanke vielleicht
für die neunte grünen dass überall rum
und aber scheiß drauf scheißt auf
mallorca ist ja alles nur einmal im jahr
aber scheiß drauf und woran merkst du
das war ein titel gut ankommt oder wenn
er nicht so gut ankamen wie es das
bemerke oben auf der bühne schnellst und
fängt an zu der refrain komm der frank
ist bei diesen der refrain ist bei
diesem song absolut das wichtigste
und wenn die leute schon beim zweiten
mal mit grünen ja sondern nicht nur 20
oder 200 oder 1000 sondern zwei 3000
leute auf einmal mitsingen so komisch
dass wir mal alle mitsingen
daran merkt man dass man schon oder wenn
man dann die diskothek verletzt genoway
collins und die leute grünen mich an mit
dem dritten titel ewiger ja die singen
untereinander und der straße singen sich
an gegenseitig sie zum betteln
das kann man sich nicht vorstellen ihren
in deutschland jetzt sehr viel regen hat
man ja bisher schon diesen sommer wieder
wobei es gibt keinen sommer seien mehr
und wenn man jetzt so seine laufbahn
sind schauspieler hättet ihr das jemals
damals in der lindenstraße träumen
lassen dass du mal stimmungssänger was
du bist du da überhaupt nicht einmal
rein gerutscht
ich bin ich bin der rheinische
frohnaturen also wichtig familien und
familie macht keiner was verein war ich
und ich immer so geheim für mich
gesungen da kam ich in dieses berühmte
dschungelcamp 2006 ich bin absoluter
schlager absoluter karneval feiern von
vorne bis hinten früher jetzt arbeite
ich da habe ich da
früher habe ich da wirklich mit gefeiert
von weiberfastnacht bis zum rosenmontag
komplett und dann kam ich 26 ins
dschungelcamp und vor lauter langeweile
für mich schlagartig zu sehen wie ich
sie kenne also mit spaß gemacht
dan brown kann glocken große
plattenfirma mit der cd macht ernst zu
nehmender schauspieler
ich kann doch jetzt nicht alle
schlagertitel singen eigentlich doch
noch reden lassen gerne überreden lassen
hat man meinen ersten segeln weil ich
glaube ich geht schon wieder los und ich
denke dass sehr laut er wollte den
zweiten titel der zweite titel ließ wer
bist denn du bist auch getötet er kann
der dritte vierte fünfte
jetzt bin ich schon im 8 was läuft denn
besser schauspielerei oder voller
schauspielen oder stimmungssänger sein
also jetzt mal so zwei drei jahre in
meinem leben da lief fast gar nichts
nach dem krieg aus allem raus geholt und
jetzt überwiegt mehr die musik aber es
kommt auch wieder die schauspielerei ich
mache momentan beides und beides lässt
sich gut vereinbaren
in der woche dreht am wochenende stehe
ich auf dem the party bedingt sich das
so beides dass man die eine popularität
für das andere nutzt um umgekehrt also
kommen die schauspieler anfragen wieder
seitdem du mit der musik erfolg hast
oder wie ist das mutter vielleicht doch
hinzufügen wenn ich habe eine ziemlich
bewegte vergangenheit und hat viel
verbrannte erde hinterlässt in der
filmbranche und ich war nicht nur
zuverlässig und das heißt das dass ein
ganzes ausgedrückt nicht mehr
zuverlässig ja ich war wir reden hier
von jahren
wie konnte man keine texte mehr merken
ich bin nicht zu drei tage erschienen
ein ernsthaftes problem gehabt und
welches war das google in abhängig ok
und habe ich therapieren lassen ich habe
sechs therapien dafür braucht die sechs
hat angeschlagen hatte schalter bap
gemacht oder wie kommt das dass ich
heute sehr oft und machte erste
therapiewahl auch die zweite
funktioniert man kommt irgendwie nicht
los wann ist der moment da dass man
loskommt wann ist der moment da also bei
mir war's schon wirklich so eine minute
vor zwölf
ich habe die frau verloren die kinder
die freunde die realität ich war habe
meine eigene welt gelebt und so um einen
lindstrand verloren in frankreich
absolut ist das ja ja ja ich bin raus
geschmissen worden
und ich bin ja der einer der
beliebtesten figuren in der lindenstraße
gewesen immer noch nie gedacht dass ich
raus weiß bis jetzt leider nicht mehr
tragbar wir müssen jetzt reagieren und
wir müssen jetzt die kleine entlassen
wie 18 jahren waren es schon war der
schon genehmigt das war schon sehr hart
das war dann soll der gipfel aber alles
um mich rum fing an zu bröckeln also
familie freunde vor 400 jahren noch
nichtmals fünf euro aber richtig breit
keine kohle nicht noch nichtmals ein
wohnsitz gehabt was obdachlos ich war
obdachlos ja ich habe meiner schwester
gelebt dann habe ich bei meiner ex frau
gelegt im kinderzimmer von meiner
tochter wie man getrennt wir aber
trotzdem aufgenommen er hat sich
trotzdem auf ihre als meine
westernfreunde mittlerweile
allerbeste freundin ich meine ja der
viel mit mir durch gemacht da also ab
zehn jahre will er in das ist schon
harter tobak hat sie dir verziehen
ich glaube ja wir sind die besten
freunde aber was ist das das ist man sei
dankbar dass war es wieder so richtig
hingekriegt hat ja ich will auf jeden
fall dankbar dass ich überhaupt anlegen
wieder in die reihe gekriegt habe ich
meine zweier ich habe ja ganz unten und
der weg nach oben wurden immer wieder
wieder steine linke legt ich habe mir
auch selber gelegt oder wo sind sie denn
von anderen sowie als auch ja aber ich
muss sagen seit drei jahren bin ich von
so was von in der spur läuft alles und
er läuft alles privates umfeld und
familie ist mittlerweile bei mir
wirklich a und rot
ich liebe meine kinder waren ich habe
ein sensationelles verhältnis meinen
kindern
mein sohn macht michael hinz demnächst
wieder zum opa ich werde am montag 38
und in yoga oper der familie steht bei
mir an allererster stelle an anna an
erster stelle
dazu glücklich momentan gute frage nur
sagen jaja möglich das habe ich bestimmt
schon seit zehn jahren nicht mehr sagen
können
momentan kann ich sagen gehen was ich
habe und erreicht hat bin ich total
glücklich wenn beim umfeld mit meinen
freunden alles bis jetzt stimmt alles
okay hätte es was wäre passiert wenn das
anders gelaufen wäre
oder ist es gut so dass es so gelaufen
wie es jetzt gelaufen ist
ich glaube es ist gut so dass es so dass
ich diesen
weg gehen musste weil so richtig da wo
ich jetzt bin und wenn ich der ich jetzt
bin ich sehr geprägt und zu dem gemacht
was muss passieren weil sonst weiß ich
nicht wo ich woran lag das denn dass du
so jung schon in die lindenstraße
eingestiegen ist kriegt man hat man da
nicht das verhältnis zwischen diese
arbeit popularität wo ist da wo kommt
man da aus der spur
das ist ja man hat junge arbeiterfamilie
das können wir leihen
und als ich anfing internet straße war
sonntags noch der normale junge und
montag
sonntags kann man die lindenstraße
montag bilder im schulbus habe ich im
schulbus gesessen und jeder kannte mich
leute war damals helfer haben die linzer
damals wurde die linzer von glaube ich
14 millionen menschen geguckt ich war
von heute auf morgen
berühmt ist da sage ich war und das war
auch zu anderen problem für mich weil
die freunde habe ich dann gelöst und
viele freunde verloren freunde ist finde
ich am anfang sehr schwer aber für ihn
damit zu leben
wenn ich jetzt erklären wir drei
gerutscht bin
es würde den rahmen sprengen aber über
bin ich dann reingerutscht in diesen
drogensumpf weil es leider manche gerade
wirklich gang und gäbe ist da ist das
normal als würde man so oder so nicht so
erkläre aber es ist leider so ich
behaupte er auch in meiner in der ganzen
szene sind 80 prozent ln alkoholiker
drogenabhängig depressiv wohl am tablett
problem ohne alles zusammen oder alles
zusammen
multi poly dogs aber du bist raus
gekommen
du bist total happy wenn ihr seid viel
raus bist du denn auch happy dass es mit
dem biss was jetzt macht stimmungssänger
ich sag mal so wird ja der eine oder
andere kollege diebe nicht mehr so recht
ich habe spaß dabei ich liebe es ich
liebe es und die meisten bisher ich
könnte auch du weißt und ich weiß was
ich so mache aber ich habe an die
letzten die 200 grenze erreicht an
auftritten im jahr und ich erreiche im
land wird es aber schon mal sogar 200
mal im jahr trifft nur auf ja nicht nur
mallorca und franziska 200 arbeitstage
also auf arbeitstage rechnet du
arbeitest eben weiß was macht manchmal
ein paar auftritt am tag wie waren diese
wahnsinns auf mallorca 21 33
das ist arbeit wird meine stimme
sonntagsmorgens höre ich mich so an es
ist wirklich harte arbeit aber man muss
sich lieben und leben wenn man es nur so
runter holt manch andere kollegen wollte
jetzt keine namen nennen
dann funktionierte soll nicht oder nur
begrenzt und ich will ja lange nicht
erhalten
aber wenn sie mich jetzt fragen würdest
entscheide dich oder schon gerne rein
könnte jetzt ich liebe beides und auch
wenn die andere kollegen mich belächeln
die ernst weil die theaterschauspieler
also die lachten mich aber viel aussagen
wie kann man denn so was machen für den
damit mein geld ich habe spaß dabei und
ich lege mir das was zu sein verhältnis
zum publikum
ich bin absolut davon ich bin im volk
star zum anfassen
manche kollegen sehr auf der bühne die
machen ihr ding gegen noch nichtmals
runter und verteilt autogramme ich mein
letztes minister ja das war mindestens
runter geht oder so zu den leuten und
hallo sei von den leuten leben wir und
die haben wir das zu verdanken dass wir
da stehen wo wir stehen
aber es ist also ein kleines geschäft
als kinder lacht das ist so
ich kenne die leute sich nicht
vorstellen macht über 200 auftritte mir
ich bin ein absoluter bulgarien
sonnenstand bulgarien goldstrand
südtirol österreich schweiz unterwegs
ist das eigentlich so ein weltklub ich
habe das video gesehen hier aus bonn mit
michael wendler hat sich gerade wieder
vertragen wenn wir hier vertragen euro
hatte beobachten wollte auch der
weltladen
ich wollte helfen ich wollte herren
aller gewerke
ich bin vom nachnamen also ein wenn auch
nicht hatten ein privates problem was
ich jetzt hier nicht willig breit treten
möchte die andere uns ausgesprochen das
hat mir gut getan ich glaub ich auch
sehr gut getan mittlerweile telefonieren
wir auch wieder einer weile suchen wir
uns auch wieder langsam daran weil im
grunde märz kann einer sagen aber wenn
es aber da will grunde im herzen ganz
tief zu bohren ist eigentlich kein
verkehrter aber wenn man tief bohrt
viele schichten durch aber so ist halt
ein netter und jetzt ist ja mal richtig
und die nase gefallen
jetzt glaube ich könnte aber gut und ist
das denn so ein kreis von leuten ihr
trefft euch wahrscheinlich wandert
unterwegs wie so peter wackel der
funktioniert und elena fischer und ihre
geht wahrscheinlich tritt zusammen auf
und abends hat er auch noch einen
privaten club zusammen oder nicht
auseinander
man sieht sich man versteht man sich
mehr oder weniger aber wenn man erfolg
hat also in dieser branche und einem
alles andere nichts nicht schon sehr
hart muss man auch einmal lernen mit
umzugehen und das ganze aber ich habe
gelernt
ich mach mein ding und ich bin wie ich
bin ich verstehe mich nicht und wäre
damit ankommen ich habe dem rechten
fleck sein ich habe mein herz auf dazu
ihn sagen was ich denke wenn die leute
oder kollegen damit
die straße kommen also pech gehabt als
einfach und kein alkohol
jetzt geht gar nicht ich habe nie gesagt
aber wenn die leute mich ein problem ist
hat dieses andere kommt aber solche hat
ein anderes problem jetzt habe ich bin
ja immer noch süchtig nach schokolade
nein das ist schon geladen war es ist
wirklich ein schokoladen bauch okay nach
zwei schubladen aber locker okay aber
das ist ja noch leidenschaftlicher
hobbykoch ich mir gerne viele sachen aus
ich esse gerne das ist so meine sucht
das lebensqualität dann wünsche ich dir
damit mit diesem süchten noch viel spaß
erfolg und rückt vor einigen daumen für
reis drauf aber scheiß drauf aber
scheint weil es noch einmal mehrere
namen ja was ich wollte über die mit
über grammatik reden grammatik haben am
new yorker ist ein ort der kann ja nicht
nur einmal im jahr sein
der ist immer einmal im jahr kann
weihnachten sein oder ostern aber doch
nicht new york oder kramer weiter alle
die meisten einmal mehr ein ort um alle
ist steht ja für party okay für party
und für einmal im jahr falls dahin und
das hieß auch raus das ist mein okay
also in diesem sinne ist kein ort
sondern ein geheimes sind meine eigene
serien auf jeden fall wie du ja
vielen dank vielleicht